[Music]
joseph in kalamazoo hey joe what's up
hey um so i am 22 years old and i have
20k in debt and i
am currently paying off three very
predatory payday loans that are eating
me alive inside i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired awesome
so how can we help man
well
i guess first and foremost though three
payday loans have some of the most
egregious uh apr rates i've seen in my
entire life
two of them have one of them has 400 and
the worst one out of the three has 690
apr
40 payments
what is there a prepay penalty
there is no prepaid penalty how much is
in all three of those bonds how much are
they no
in some the worst though in some it's
about 400 800
i'd say about 1100 in total all three
how much do you make
i make about 45 000 a year after taxes
what caused you to go to a payday lender
out of all people in the first place
um
i've been struggling living paycheck to
paycheck and and i had no emergency fund
and most days my bank account is either
negative or has barely a few ones in it
and so i've had to make some pretty hard
decisions uh poor decisions nonetheless
but uh
all right so here's what we're gonna do
uh i'm gonna turn over to george here
for a second but
um
i want you to get a couple of bricks
once you go find them even if you have
to go to the grocery i mean to the
hardware store and pay pay 50 cents for
one okay get a couple of them
i want you to get some masking tape and
put it on there
or just get a magic marker and write on
there
stupid thing you did a dumb loan and a
dumb loan or i got desperate and then i
found myself negative whatever
i want you to hold that sucker for a
minute till it gets heavy
and then i want you to go to the nearest
lake or river and throw it in there
and be
done with this okay because here's what
i can hear your voice the shame of what
happened to you is prohibiting you from
launching into outer space to get the
stuff knocked out
every step you take is you're carrying
the well you're so stupid i can't
believe this and now
this 600 percent interest rate is a slap
in your face every day but you're
feeling it as a stupid tax right
yeah stop damn stop get done with it
joseph how much money do you have in the
bank right now
negative 445
so sorry what's your day job
i uh i'm an hvac uh heating and cooling
technician okay can you work extra hours
yes i can okay
i'm going to be working 80 hours a week
until this mess is cleaned up and i'm
definitely focusing on these insane
payday loans first and you're going to
be on a shoestring budget eating rice
and beans more than ever before my
favorite meal so that's that's good news
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
hook you up with a financial coaching
session with one of our trained
financial coaches and gift you one year
of ramsay plus to dive into the budget
focus on that because that's what you
can control and every dollar is going to
have a name and we're not going to spend
any money on anything but this debt and
keeping the lights on
that's it are you in
i am in boom austin's going to pick up
we're going to make sure he gets you
connected to one of our financial
coaches and ramsay plus watch all the
financial peace videos i want you to get
so angry at this that you are standing
outside of the payday lender with a sign
that says avoid this scam and i want you
driving for uber or ubereats or
something by this weekend you got 48
hours to make that happen i want you
down at local coffee shop working from
4am to 7 00 am to get another three
hours in go pick up a shift in the
evenings washing dishes
your life is over for the next 24 months
and then
everything
looks different how do payday lenders
sleep at night i have no idea very
comfortable mattresses paid on the
desperation of hurting 190 interest
is there a bigger scam in america